Bonjour à toutes et à tous !
Est-ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé
de vous retrouver face à un tableau
et de n'absolument pas savoir où regarder ?
Tellement ... de détails...
Dans ces moments-là, on est tenté de penser :
"Bon... Non mais vraiment je m'y connais pas assez..."
"Je sais pas vraiment où regarder parce que ..."
"Bon moi et l'art..."
"Pff ...Voilà quoi..."
Et bien, figurez-vous que votre regard de
néophytes peut en apprendre autant
aux chercheurs que celui des experts,
grâce à un savant mélange d'informatique,
de sciences humaines et d'histoire des arts.
Ca fait longtemps que les chercheurs se questionnent
sur la réception des oeuvres d'art :
Où le regard du spectateur se pose-t-il ?
Ce regarde varie-t-il en fonction
de l'âge, de la formation, du contexte
dans lequel se trouve le spectateur ?
Alors certes, on a déjà eu recours à des
questionnaires ou à l'eye-tracking,
(oculométrie, dans la langue de Molière, s'il vous plaît),
mais ces deux procédés
présentent plusieurs limitations.
Le questionnaire nécessite un recours au langage
qui est plus limité chez l'enfant
et plus expert chez l'historien de l'art, par exemple.
Quant à l'eye-tracking,
il ne tient compte que de l'endroit où
les yeux se posent sur l’œuvre,
sans savoir si le spectateur regarde vraiment cette zone,
tout en lui attribuant du sens,
ou s'il l'effleure simplement du regard.
Je veux dire...
On a déjà tous regardé une chose,
tout en pensant à une autre.
Hummmm
Et si je mangeais un brownie.
Le sociologue Mathias Blanc, lui, a choisi
une solution alternative :
L'utilisation du tracé.
Armés de tablettes tactiles,
les spectateurs sont invités
à indiquer à l'aide de traits, de points et de ronds,
les éléments du tableau
qui attirent leurs regards
et qu'ils estiment importants.
Exit la barrière sociale du langage.
Ce questionnaire est entièrement visuel,
puisque c'est à partir d'une reproduction du tableau
que les spectateurs s'expriment.
Le nom de ce formidable joujou analytique :
l'Iconik Analysis Toolkit,
ou IKONIKAT pour les intimes.
Et croyez-moi IKONIKAT, ça change tout !
Prenez par exemple
la réunion musicale des frères Le Nain.
Beaucoup de spectateurs se montraient
perplexes quant au titre du tableau,
qui ne correspondait pas à ce qu'il évoquait chez eux.
Cet intitulé a été donné par des experts,
bien après la réalisation de l’œuvre,
en se basant sur une interprétation
très savante mais pas unique.
En effet, les relevés des tracés montrent
que les spectateurs non experts
eux y voient plutôt une scène de fiançailles.
Cette interprétation, elle est loin d'être incohérente.
Elle est même tout à fait plausible.
Et elle permet d'engager un dialogue très intéressant entre le savoir expert
et le regard néophyte
Bien sûr pour en arriver là,
il faut analyser une quantité astronomique de tracés
Afin d'obtenir des statistiques iconométriques exploitables,
il faut donc faire intervenir
un brin magie
ou d'informatique en l'occurrence.
On peut ainsi en apprendre beaucoup sur la manière
dont Roger, cadre supérieur,
féru d'histoire de l'art, venu seul au musée
regarde une œuvre des frères Le Nain
et savoir en quoi sa manière de voir le tableau
diffère de celle de Lucie, 10 ans,
venue en visite scolaire avec toute sa classe.
En superposant les différents tracés,
on obtient ainsi une carte de chaleur
où les zones les plus chaudes
correspondent à celles où le nombre d'intéractions
a été le plus important.
On peut ainsi comparer les résultats
entre un groupe
ayant été sensibilisé à l'histoire de l'art
et un groupe n'ayant pas reçu de formation particulière dans le domaine.
Prenez par exemple, cette allégorie de la justice
signée Jean-Baptiste Wicar.
Les néophytes se sont focalisés
sur l'aspect violent de la scène
avec des tracés autour du glaive et du bébé suspendu.
Pendant ce temps-là,
un groupe ayant reçu des leçons sur le sujet
et informé sur ce qu'est une allégorie,
s'est concentré sur les mains de Salomon
qui, posée sur son cœur et tendue vers l'avant,
symbolisent la justice.
IKONIKAT, contre toute attente,
y compris celle de son créateur Mathias Blanc,
se révèle avoir des retombés
dans le champ de la pédagogie.
En effet, savoir comment les publics
observent les œuvres d'art, permet aux musées
de mieux adapter leurs scénographies
afin d'optimiser l'expérience et la réception artistiques.
Vraiment ?
C'est là-dessus que tu te focalises ?
Pour reprendre notre allégorie de la justice,
un musée pourra choisir par exemple
d'installer un cartel explicatif
afin de signaler aux spectateurs
la symbolique derrière la gestuelle de Salomon.
Ce type de dispositif permet
d'adapter le discours muséal
à différents types de spectateurs.
Ce qui est essentiel,
car le sens et l'interprétation d'une œuvre d'art
ne sont pas figés.
IIs évoluent avec le temps
en fonction de celles et ceux qui la regardent.
En retour, les regards néophytes peuvent aussi
beaucoup en apprendre aux experts.
Donc la prochaine fois que vous
ne saurez pas quoi regarder
dans un tableau,
dites-vous que les conservateurs
ont autant à en apprendre
de vous, que vous d'eux.
Hey ! Attends mais ...
Comment on fait pour les monochromes alors ?
Ah ben c'est sûr, tout de suite, si tu
débarques avec Malevitch...
ça risque de noircir le tableau.
Si la vidéo vous a plu,
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner.
Et allez faire un tour sur la chaîne de NaRt.